Jordan Belford has responded to my
allegations and I want to talk about it
some of you may know Jordan from The
Wolf of Wall Street which is based on
his life as a scammer more recently he's
in hot water for being involved in
another scam Omega Pro and having money
in a 500 million dollar Ponzi scheme now
I reached out to Jordan about this ahead
of time and his team's response was that
I was being wildly misleading so even
though it's not a big deal because he's
kind of a a small fish in this whole
thing I wanted to settle it because it's
a little bit annoying when people tell
me I'm taking them out of context when
in fact everything that I'm saying is
completely correct so we will be reading
their whole response to me to make sure
you get the full context and I'll warn
you in advance they're gonna try to
trick us let's start off right from the
top hi Jordan my name is coffeezilla I'm
an investigative journalist I noticed
you had a balance of 325 000 with
Traders domain on September 20th 2022
via your company future gen LLC and also
participated as a paid spokesman of some
kind for Omega Pro both massive
interconnected Ponzi schemes and they
said the following in response Mr
Belford is not nor has ever been a paid
spokesman of Omega Pro he actually
declined their offer Omega Pro hired Mr
Belford to speak at two of their events
about sales and Entrepreneurship I know
you're confused you think maybe I had a
stroke no I'm reading it exactly how
they said it he says I've never been
hired as a paid spokesman
but I have I have actually gotten hired
twice
let me explain it to you spokesman means
you're endorsing the business as a
legitimate business which Mr Belford
obviously would never do so I'm not
advising you to go out and find some get
rich quick scheme which this is not it's
a legitimate business okay not
understanding how they're saying he's
not a paid spokesman here since he was
paid and seems to be a spokesman either
way they continue these were two of over
150 events that Mr Belford spoke at that
year and he has never had any
affiliation with the company and only
vaguely knows what they do
and I had to laugh at this part because
I'm just thinking to myself like yeah
isn't it that funny moment we can all
relate to when you're speaking at the
biggest event of the year for a company
in Panama and you have no idea what they
do sounds really reasonable guys sounds
sounds legit in fact during his speech
with Omega Pro he specifically stated
that he was not there to speak about
their business or making Investments as
he was unfamiliar with what they do now
it's at this point we're going to have
to talk about Jordan's get rich quick
claims because that's another part of my
question to them because in this speech
where he has no idea what the business
is Jordan claims you gotta get rich
quick which you know is a bit of a red
flag when you're talking about a get
rich quick scheme there's only one way
to get rich in this world
and that is quickly you gotta get rich
quick not surprisingly Jordan had an
issue with the fact I said I was gonna
play that clip his team said in response
the above quote you provided is wildly
misleading as it is only the first half
of the quote the full quote from the
transcript is below and Mr Belfort
stands by it to this very day and I'm
going to jump to the second half of the
quote because you've already read the
first part you got to get rich quick
okay and the reason for that is because
we live in a world that's far too
expensive to get rich slowly you can't
get rich slowly over time between
inflation and currency devaluations and
all the hard work by the time you get
rich it's too late but I'm not talking
about a get rich quick scheme that's not
what I mean I'm not advising you to go
out and find some get rich quick scheme
which is not a legitimate business I
know what you're thinking I just got
roasted I thought the same thing I
thought maybe I was wrong about Jordan
Belfort poor guy is getting paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to talk
about a company he knows nothing about
and he's being criticized for it I mean
I couldn't believe it what I'd almost
done because I hadn't made the video yet
mind you I was requesting for comment
and I was about to apologize uh when I
actually watched the real video and
remembered the full quote you gotta get
rich quick okay and the reason for that
is because we live in a world that's far
too expensive to get rich slowly you
just can't get rich slowly over time
between inflation and currency
devaluations and all the hard work it
does by the time you get rich it's too
late and I will tell you this
this is a fact I'm not talking about
a get rich quick scheme that's not what
I mean and so I'm not advising you to go
out and find some get rich quick scheme
which this is not it's a legitimate
business okay did you catch it Jordan's
team has conveniently edited the quote
from I'm not advising you to go out and
find some get rich quick scheme which
this is not meaning Omega Pro is not a
get rich quick scheme it's a legitimate
business okay and they changed it to say
this so I'm not advising you to go out
and find some get rich quick scheme
which is not a legitimate business it's
a totally different meaning in one of
them you're endorsing the company and
the real one you're calling it a
legitimate business in the fake quote
that they provided me all of that
context is gone I wonder why maybe it's
because it shows that Jordan is at least
pretending to know what this company
does because you wouldn't call something
a legitimate business if you had no idea
know what they did right they also left
out another part where Jordan tells the
crowd it's great that you all believe in
Omega Pro but don't look a gift horse in
the mouth don't second guess it just
look a around you who can smell
money could you spell the money yes
ladder can you smell it yes
[Applause]
why is that why is that why is it that
within this room right now there is so
much success
so much money being made why why is that
well a couple of things number one
there's a lot of belief in the room you
all believe in what you're doing you
believe in the cause you've been making
money yourselves you've been able to
convince others to do the same to join
up and to make money right that's what's
going on here so there's belief but I
will tell you this there's an old saying
that we have in English
and that saying goes don't look a gift
horse in the mouth
meaning these these types of moments
in each one of your lives
they don't come along that often they
just don't
this is insane in fact you could replace
Omega Pro with literally any penny stock
that Jordan was selling back in the day
that he got arrested and it feels like
the same thing the whole thing about
like you know there's so much money here
you believe this is an incredible
opportunity but just don't look look at
it too closely don't look a gift horse
in the mouth it's barely gonna come back
again you know it's once in a lifetime
this is the same thing it's the same
scam just a new way to do it right it's
just not penny stocks it's this Omega
Pro nonsense and they had the audacity
to leave that quote out twist another
quote and then try to what get me to
walk back what I was gonna say now
finally we're gonna get to the last
claim of mine which is that Jordan had
money locked in Trader's domain which
once again they told me that I was being
wildly misleading about uh but then they
said this as far as Traders domain goes
Mr Belford has no knowledge of Traders
domain or any link that they may have
had with Omega Pro other than that a
very close friend of his said that he he
was making a lot of money with a managed
account and he convinced Mr Belford to
give this money manager a shot so Mr
Belford made a small speculative
investment there of approximately two
hundred thousand dollars small
investment of two hundred thousand
dollars who in their right mind look
bear in mind this guy is like a scam
professional right he did it for years
he then puts money in a thing that seems
too good to be true offshore Forex
brokerage with zero research like we're
supposed to believe that I mean
personally I don't believe it that
Jordan Belfort is looking at this thing
that looks like probably what he used to
sell and goes yeah this seems like a
good opportunity
uh according to them quote after a few
months of seeing profits Mr Belford felt
that it was too good to be true and
requested his money back that's when the
problem started it took many months and
constant legal threats to get back his
original investment which he eventually
got back with a small profit so he did
make money what are we wrong about it's
so funny like they claimed I was being
wildly misleading but both of the things
I'm alleging here that he was publicly
speaking for a get rich quick scheme and
seeming to pitch it basically that's
true he also had money in Trader's
domain also true he apparently made
money with it which we didn't even know
but also we have to seriously
interrogate whether Jordan knew nothing
about Trader's domain just like we had
to with Omega Pro because they then say
quote he then closed his account and
that was that he would be willing to
discuss off the Record more of what he
suspects is happening there as some of
his friends were convinced to open up an
account there by the same person never
got their money back and just to be be
clear despite this managed account
offering Mr Belford a 10 override in any
money he could bring in he never
recommended it to any other person
because from the very beginning he
always considered it a speculative
investment and had done no due diligence
rather he made the investment based on
the word of a friend let me get this
straight Jordan knows nothing about
Trader's domain no due diligence but if
we talk off the Record so that I can't
say what he says he's claiming he's
going to explain what's happening are
you kidding Hey listen I know nothing
about this but if we go behind closed
doors I'll explain the whole thing
that doesn't make any sense well that's
nonsense I I mean look this whole thing
is ridiculous and of course the reason
I'm talking about this is not because
Jordan was like the big player in all
this he was not by a long shot I only
bring up his response as an exemplary
way that these influencers and speakers
they just want to have it both ways look
they want to make all the money when
they speak right all the money wild
speaking fees of hundreds of thousands
of dollars a post and then when it all
goes wrong they want to be held to zero
accountability or to put it another way
they don't want you to look a gift horse
in the mouth even when it bites you you
already paid me right